our next award goes to wettest spherical
harmonic lighting technology that allows
CG artists to quickly see the results of
changing lighting material and set
layouts in the geometry of the scene or
on a character like they did for Gollum
this technology is the basis for
rendering complex scenes with greater
lighting and visual detail at
substantial cost savings its
calculations provide a methodology for
computer graphics lighting that
accelerates rendering for large
complicated environments since its first
implementation on avatar has been used
on all films at what a digital for the
creation of the spherical harmonics
based efficient lighting system the
Academy presents its technical
achievement award to Martin hill John
Allen and Nick McKenzie Wow I'd like to
thank the academy and especially the the
subcommittee you really took the time to
to evaluate our submission and I know
they put a lot of work into that huge
huge thank you to everyone in West
digital they really embrace the
technology and have just created a
phenomenal body of work with it there's
an enormous man of talent and obviously
all of the work we did couldn't have
been could have been realized on screen
without the artists special thank you to
Jolla Terry you not only saw the
techniques potential early on but also
personally tested it and helped
contribute to it whilst they I'd just
like to thank my family Catherine Mina
and Theo
it is obviously an honor to be here this
evening and for for that I'd like to
thank the academy for recognizing the
work that we have contributed to over a
number of years on a personal note I
would like to thank friends and family
and colleagues that have indirectly and
directly contributed to this and and
final words i would say that i'd also
like to thank the artists that take our
ideas and take our work and produce
amazing images so thank you to them i'd
like to thank the academy obviously
everyone at wetter who's taken our
technology and made it great i'd also
like to thank all of the visual effects
supervisors producers and directors that
we've worked for that are constantly
challenging us to do better and faster
and cheaper thank you